hey guys I am Jeff McDonald here at tax
Australia and today we're going to be
making a live top 5 video about favorite
Australian developed games with these
lovely people
my friend is a awesome mobile game where
you have different panels like a comic
but you can switch them around to change
the order of the actions it's got a
really pretty art and wonderful music as
well so yeah it's a really great game
portal and the pre-sequel is that
between Borland's and Borderlands 2 and
basically it gives you the gist on how
handsome Jack became the big douche so
it's great graphics and how often so you
should definitely try it out this mantle
is an upcoming indie game that has been
created in Australia and it's all about
fighting your opponents who are robots
actually robots you can customize your
characters you get to self detonate
and of course your head blows off and
you can latch yourself on to another
opponent and then explode fantastic game
screen sheet is a game that goes back to
local split-screen multiplayer but with
the twist that instead of not looking at
a person screen you are encouraged to
look at the other person's screen as
it's necessary
everyone is invisible and you have to be
looking at their screen to know where
they are and get clues from the
environment to be able to find where
they are and shoot them
all right so ty the tasmanian tiger is
kind of like a collectathon sort of
along the lines of banjo kazooie and
Donkey Kong 64 might love it might hate
it but it's awesome because it has a lot
of Australian words like dinky die and
it is quintessentially Australian and
you travel through a lot of environments
like the Great Barrier Reef the outback
a lot of tin shed and desert locations
it's just great you collect boomerangs
those are your weapons your family are
Tasmanian Tigers who have like
disappeared and captured by a like a
cassowary and you've got it like
turncoat Tasmanian Tigers how could it
possibly be better so those are some of
the awesome Australian developed games
that have been made there are even more
at PAX Australia here thanks for joining
us with some more content
you